weder hose möchte wie hast du deinen
entzog verarbeitet mittlerweile habe ich
meine zu super verarbeitet also ich habe
ein neues leben angefangen
ich lebe ich lebe besser als je zuvor
und freier und ich werde es nicht mehr
anpacken definitiv nicht bis es weiter
fragt wie siehst du zum schauspielern
gekommen
in der lindenstraße wolle man quasi
ausgeschrieben habe ich mich ganz normal
beworben das war
90 glaube ich und ganz normal 100 leute
von 150 150 unter den zehn von zehn
unter den 5 und dann wurde die wie 20 9
65 hat folgende frage dazu dass es zur
wir rocken diese stadt einen mega styles
remix gab da die hands up
beziehungsweise dance chorszene doch
relativ unbekannt ist und zwischen dir
und dem tobias von den megatrends doch
schon ein gewisser unterschied bei der
bekanntheit vorhanden ist und stellt mir
erste frage die kenntlich den muss
beantworten
weißt du warum wer ist dieser tobias von
mir das salz ich will es hören
also ich habe wir rocken diese stadt
gemacht ja aber ich kenne meine version
von redkings und rico bernasconi aber
den megastar kenne ich nicht meint
sigrid wie war es für dich immer so eine
fiese und gaster rolle in der linken
straße zu spielen also wann empfinde
mich nicht immer einfach den bösewicht
zu spielen weil ich der bösewicht der
nation ich war immer nur der fiese olli
da haben sie mich früher genannt wenn
sie über die straße gegangen bin oder es
gab auch sogar leute die haben die
straßenseite gewechselt wenn sie mich
gesehen haben
das war für mich zu anfang etwas aber
mit der zeit gelernt damit umzugehen
aber das gerade das hat für mich den
reiz ausgemacht diesen zu spielen weil
etwas zu spielen was beim privaten leben
nicht ist das habe ich schon sehr
gereizt also die das böse
habt ihr das auch probleme bereit ist
also vor allen dingen als junger mensch
dass man dann so mit dieser rolle
identifiziert wird vom publikum gerade
in der lindenstraße ist es ja so als ich
anfing
in den anfangszeiten 1909 100 200 300
495 so viele menschen gesehen haben
einfach gedacht die haben muss privat 10
arschloch wein und das weiß einig aber
es war schon schwere für mich privat so
latour
ich habe bei den dreharbeiten immer
natürlich mache ich mein geld so wenn
die kameraleute und böse anlass aber ich
will ja keine böse sein ich will die
leute unterhalten dass leute mich lachen
und judith aber warum ich dann da
reingerutscht bin wo ich bin vor
etlichen jahren mit mit der sucht das
war für mich damals erfolgsdruck gar
nicht mal so sagen also ich hab ich vier
mal an das zeug zu probieren
da wurde das aus manchmal würde man alle
drei monate
alle zwei monate alle zwei monate jeden
monat jeden monat an alle paar wochen
noch alle drei wochen alle zwei wochen
und damals dann wöchentlich und
nirgendwo da rein gerutscht und der zeit
war ich ziemlich ab frankreich in dem
was ich gemacht habe und wolle nicht an
diesem erfolgsdruck einfach ich konnte
ihm einfach nicht standhalten ich habe
immer gedacht wenn ich das konsumieren
dann bin ich stärker ich bin kreativer
ich bin wach anstatt alles bewältigen
aber dem war nicht so das ist man bemüht
sich das selber aber ich kann wirklich
geraten
das sollte niemals anzupacken also ich
hab wirklich alle höhen und tiefen
drogenszene durch geschichten von leuten
genommen
alle drogen den scheiße die falle auch
nikotin
aber ich weiß ich hab ich wurde damals
paranoiden wahnvorstellungen
ich habe mal sehr in selbstmitleid
gewartet ich der lebenslustiger mensch
der welt bin auf allen vieren durch die
wohnung gekrochen
man kann darüber lachen aber das kann
zum lachen im moment ist und david
paranoid wohnung schleichen wird also
die droge kokain ist absolut der teufel
ist auch der teufel das tue ich der
teufel ja ich bin der tod zwar von der
schippe gesprungen
vor infekt gehabt das war so ein
abschlag vom buchwert so mal auf und ich
hatte aussetzer gehabt über eine minute
aber ich bin da ja ich war ganz unten
möglich ganz unten wirklich ganz unten
und keiner hat mich geglaubt also noch
wenige leute an mich geglaubt und ich
habe ich so eine scheiße wieder
rauskommen aber wenn du das schaffst
aber man hat man mir klick gemacht ich
bin in die therapie kann die sechste
therapeut angeschlagen ich habe mich auf
alles eingelassen waren erzählt bekannte
die betty-ford-klinik ich hatte sieben
therapeuten die sich um mich gekümmert
habe ich mal therapie zu anfang oder ich
mache kein bild der kunsttherapie und
der beute mal ein baum zu baum mal ich
habe deshalb die kombination das allemal
therapie streichen therapie
gruppentherapie einzeltherapie film
therapie das alles in allem das war die
therapie und da habe ich mich beim
letzten mal wenn sie sagt mal ne 8 dann
mal in der 8 und hab' ich drauf
eingelassen um mich fallen lassen und
dann immer geklappt zu themen noch eine
frage haben war von mister mathematik
oder matsch tomate
würdest du dein leben von grund auf noch
einmal ändern wenn du es könnte und dann
einen völlig anderen weg einschlagen
die frage gut ich glaube nein es hat
mich zu dem gemacht zudem das hat mich
zu dem gemacht der er denn ich bin und
ich würde das das war schon so dass wir
da so passiert ist weil sie mich sehr
stark gemacht